the European People's Party we are the
Christian Democrats of this continent so
we offend your based and we are strongly
in favor of Europe er the founding party
of the European Union the European
People's Party often referred to as the
EPP is the center-right parliamentary
group
it's the largest political group in the
European Parliament with 182 seats the
EPP group in Parliament has existed in
one form or another since 1953 making it
the oldest pan-european political group
the other party who wants to have
strictly stormwater control there's a
readiness to how people who really need
our help we need fair trade agreements
so our global dimension is for us
important and it's the third element we
want to create chops into saying in
dialogues European Union because
especially young people cannot have a
future those are jobs the EPP group has
MEP s from 26 of the 28 member states
with the exception of the UK and Estonia
but they have to do is to make out of
the European in order a more democratic
Europe that's why we fight for a
stronger control
[Music]